- [Voiceover] I have some
example problems here from
our equivalent vectors
exercise on Khan Academy,
so let's go through these
and like always, pause
the video and see if you can
work through them on your own.
So this first one says, "Are
vectors u and w equivalent?"
And so we can see vector u here in blue
and vector w right over here.
And we have to remember a
vector is defined by both
having a magnitude and a direction.
And so for two vectors to be
equivalent they have to have
the same magnitude and the same direction.
So when I look at these
two, they are clearly
pointing in different directions.
Vector u is pointing to the bottom right,
that's the direction it's pointing in,
and vector w is pointing
to the bottom left,
so they definitely aren't equivalent.
So they are not equivalent,
scratch that out.
So they have different
directions, different directions.
Different directions.
And also think about the magnitude.
If I just look at the
length of the arrows,
just eyeballing it,
they look pretty close.
Let me verify that.
So if I'm starting at the
initial point for vector u,
how much do I move in the x direction?
Well in the x direction
I go from negative eight
to negative three, so I
could say my change in x
is positive five, my x increases by five
as I go from the initial point,
from the x coordinate of the
initial point to the x coordinate of the
terminal point, so that length.
The magnitude of just
the x component is five.
And let's see what happens
in the y direction.
So in the y direction, I start
at y equals negative two,
right over here, and then I go down
to y equals negative eight.
So my change in y, change in y,
is equal to negative six, negative six.
Also think about this one over here.
What's my change in x?
Well I'm starting at x equals eight,
and I am going to x equals three.
So my change in x is negative five.
I'm gonna write that,
change in x is equal to,
this is my change in x, change in x.
And then what's my change in y?
Well I start at y is equal to eight
and I go down y is equal to two.
Do it just like that.
So my change in y is
equal to negative six.
Now based on the changes in x's and y's,
I can figure out the magnitude
of each of these vectors.
The magnitude of u, so I
could write it like this, the
magnitude of u, sometimes you'll
see the notation like this,
the magnitude of u, of
vector u I should say,
is going to be equal to, we're just gonna
use the pythagorean theorem here.
It's going to be the square root.
The length of this hour is just a
hypotenuse of the right triangle.
So it's going to be the
square root of five squared
plus negative six squared so
it's gonna be the square root
of 25 plus 36, which is
equal to the square root of,
what is that?
It's going to be square root of 61.
I can make that radical
a little bit smaller,
square root of 61.
Now what about vector w?
So the magnitude of vector w is,
I could use a double, those double bars.
The magnitude of vector
w, well that's going to be
the square root of negative
five squared, which is 25
plus negative six squared,
which is going to be 36.
Well that's going to be the
square root of 61 as well.
So they have the same magnitude,
just different directions.
So let's see, no they have the
same magnitude, but different directions.
Yup, that's the choice we like.
Let's do one more of these.
Are vectors u and w equivalent?
Alright, so these look pretty
equivalent just eyeballing it.
It looks like they're pointed
in the same direction,
they're going from the
bottom left to the top right.
And it looks like they're the same length,
but we can verify them.
Once again by looking at
their x and y components.
So in the x direction, or
thinking about how much we change
in x and change in y when we go from the
initial point to the terminal point.
So in the x direction, for
vector u, we go from negative
seven to negative four,
so we increased by three.
And what do we do over here?
We go from x equals two to x equals five.
So our x component once again
has a magnitude of three,
our change in x is a positive three.
And so our change in y,
what is that going to be?
Well we're going, on this
vector, from y equals...
Whoops, I'm using the wrong...
We're going from y is equal
to one to y is equal to six.
So the magnitude of the y
component, we could say, is five
or our change in y is a positive five.
And then the change in y over
here also is a positive five.
We go from negative seven to negative two.
It's also a positive five.
So notice our change in x is
the same, it's a positive three.
Our change in y is the
same, positive five.
So that let's us know that we have
the same magnitude and direction.
And so these are equivalent,
these are equivalent vectors.
And, in fact, as we'll see in
the future, you can actually
denote a vector by its components.
We could say that vector u,
vecotr u, is the vector five,
oh sorry, the vector three comma five,
our change in x comma our change in y.
And that is exactly the same as vector w.
So that is exactly the same as
vector w, has the same change
in x, same change of y as
you go from the initial
point to the tip of the
arrow, the terminal point.